Houston Texans head coach Bill O'Brien
how are you coach I'm doing fine rich
how you doing I know you're doing fine
nine straight wins nine straight double
use what were you telling your team at
Owen three coach we have real good guys
rich we have guys that that worked very
hard that understand their roles and
they understood early in the year that
we hadn't been coached our best we
hadn't played our best but you know we
were in a lot of close ball games that
if we could just continue to kind of
trust the trust of systems and trust
what we were what we were telling them
as coaches that you know we could we
could turn it around with a bunch of
guys we have here and give credit to the
players we've been able to do that and
so were you relying on any specific unit
specific players that you pulled in I'm
just wondering if you were if you did
anything out of your routine coach at OU
and three we have we have good
leadership we have six captains JJ Watt
Jonathan Joseph Brian Peters Tyrann
Mathieu DeAndre Hopkins and deshaun
Watson and I I rely on those guys
there's other guys in the locker room
Kareem Jackson Nick Martin guys that
have been here for a long time Ryan
Griffin our tight end you know we have
guys that have been around us for a
while and you know they know how we
coach we trust each other and yeah I
mean there were things that we talked
about during the time where we were
losing and we felt like if we just kind
of could you know change a couple things
here relative to scheme and maybe
individual technique and keep trying to
get better that we would we would be
okay and our players have really hung in
there well it's possible that you can
nail down your division with a win
against the cult's this weekend coach
and it's just interesting that the
turnaround began in Indianapolis with
that win in overtime where you took
advantage of an opportunity with Frank
Reich trying to win the game rather than
play for a tie were you surprised that
he made that decision in overtime of
that day in Indy no no I have great
respect for Frank and
you know Frank Frank is all about
winning he's going to do what he thinks
is best for his team to win the game and
and he made the decision to do that and
we were able to make a play and you know
that's just the way it goes in the NFL
comes down to you know one or two plays
three plays in a game and Frank the
Frank does a great job these guys
present a big challenge to us rich you
know they they have you know excellent
players at you know many different
positions starting with Andrew Luck and
py Hilton and then defensively their
rookie linebacker Darius Lehner's
playing great gathers their safety you
know jabal cheered up running me they've
got really good players that present to
present a big big challenge to us and
you know we're really just trying to be
as focused as we can on the Sunday game
that's the big challenge for us well I'm
wondering if you could take us under the
the hood here about decision-making in
moments like that in NFL games fourth
downs and yardage to go and and time on
the clock as well as position on the
field and analytics we hear so much
about you know if you go for it here as
opposed to punting that's a 15%
difference of winning and do you know
that sort of stuff off the top of your
head or have somebody who informs you of
probabilities at the moment in in the
spur of the moment coach we we
definitely study and talk about that a
lot during the week we definitely have I
personally have someone on game day that
that helps me with that really two
people one on the sideline and one up in
the press box but at the end of the day
rich it definitely to me comes down to
how the games being played like you know
for all the charts that you can look at
and I think they're important I really
do you know charts are worth noting if
you go into the game and the game really
isn't going the way you thought it was
going to go maybe you thought it was
going to be a defensive battle and it
ended up being a shootout or vice versa
and you know in the end you're always
going to try to make the best decision
for your team based on like you said
field position you know if you have a
great play you really feel good about
the play you have you know the defense
they're going to be in and you feel
really good about how it's been executed
during a week you know there's just a
lot that goes into it a lot of it is in
and and the charts don't have anything
to do with instinct you know I think the
charts help you prepare but at the end
of the day you've got to do your best
when it comes to you know having a good
feel for how the games being played
Texans head coach Bill O'Brien joining
us here on a nine-game winning streak
heading into a big game against the
Colts this Sunday at home on the Rich
Eisen show and man you've had quite an
emotional last two home games a moment
of silence for the founder of the Texans
who passed away Bob McNair and then one
of his best friends in life and I'm sure
somebody you met many times as he went
to a lot of Texans games coach in 41st
president of the United States George HW
Bush I'm wondering if you've got a great
memory about either of these gentlemen
if not the two of them together with you
yeah I have great memories of Bob McNair
you know we became you know close as the
years went on and and I really
understood especially after last season
we had a long talk at his home you know
about how he viewed the organization and
how he wanted it to be a family-oriented
organization and that he cared about
winning but he he really cared about
treating people the right way and
treating people with respect I learned a
lot about leadership from Bob McNair
rich and I'll always thank him for that
I'll always owe him for that
with President Bush I was very fortunate
when I first was hired here mr. McNair
brought myself to my wife Colleen over
to where his office was over here in
Houston and we were able to go out to
lunch with them and meet him and you
know take a picture and I was you know
I'm just a football coach I was in
complete awe of that whole situation I
mean he he told great stories that day
about being the director of the CIA
about being vice president about men you
thought about his life you know what he
did in his life it was it was incredible
and to have you know both those guys
passed away within a week of each other
to Houston legends is you know it's
pretty incredible yeah I mean I got a I
was fortunate interview President Bush
in Houston it was their first NFL
Network covered Super Bowl in Houston it
was the Patriots and the Carolina
Panthers back
the day and that at the time the new
building and I was so nervous talking to
him and he put me at ease I mean he put
me right it I mean the Secret Service
everywhere and you know taglio boo is
the Commissioner at the time was there
and Bob McNair was off to the side and
we got a whole crowd I was you know
every executive and the NFL wanted to
make sure everything was fine and
there's me and poppy bush on live
television it was nerve-racking but he
put me right at ease it was just awesome
it really was man great man he was he
had a great sense of humor and a great
way about him and he was very welcoming
I know JJ Watt you know he knows them
you know very very well and he always
talked about his sense of humor and how
easy was to to speak to and get to know
JJ Watt knows everybody doesn't he he
does man he's great player great guy he
said he is that an opportunity to meet a
lot of fantastic people he's the most
interesting man in the world I think I
think he I think he might he might just
be coached this is absolutely not only
because I am a human being and I care
about other human beings but also a
full-on straight-up concern over fantasy
football
deshaun Watson is my quarterback and I
it looks like he's taking a lot of hits
coach he's taking a lot of hits are you
concerned about that and his health well
being here always concerned about you
know every short you know obviously
DeSean you know there are times where
he's when he's taking hits I think it's
been definitely less than a what it was
earlier in the season I think some of it
we can correct from a coaching
standpoint and some of it you know is
the way he plays rich you know he he
enjoys running the football he has great
instinct about the game he he
understands you know when to slide when
to duck out of bounds but we're always
we're always talking about hey maybe
that's one hit that you don't need to
take there's no doubt about that and
we'll continue to work with him on that
and he understands it okay I just
announced with Jay Glazer that I'm
working out it has on Performance Center
for my 40-yard dash this year so I'm
getting in shape and you know my lats
are a little bit sore today the reason
why I mentioned is do you know any any
expert ation I can have to take me to
and from work to make sure I'm fine do
you know of any any sort of four-wheel
vehicle to do such a thing I don't know
I can't help you with that I know that
training with Jay Glazer is probably not
the always the best answer there because
I think it's them I think that might be
a boxing gym or something open it
fighting that he put that he trains in
or something no no it is it's but he's
getting me in shapes it's just know this
just know this and I know that you've
got I know that you've got a playing
season you got a winning streak but you
know when you see my name move up your
draft board come January February March
just know just understand where it all
start at you if you promise me that
you'll run it without you know but I
don't think you can run it in your shoot
I have to though you've got to take the
suit off nothing you have to run it put
some workout clothes on and get down in
the stance and run it nobody wants to
see that a and B that's my uniform you
know what I'm saying that's my MA
uniform you know a great chat with you
yeah we'll chat down the line and good
luck as you matriculate your way through
your your season thank you rich you're
always appreciated thank you right back
at you that's Bill O'Brien Texas head
coach the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience